a maioria han eu sou cirurgião não é a
profissão mais sexy do mundo e isso o
cirurgião de guerra
portanto imaginem sempre muito sangue eu
vou habitualmente para os sítios de onde
as pessoas saem e portanto vamos ter só
se moviam como pouca gente e 1
hoje vou mostrar uma série de cirurgias
na tv aberta
vou vou falar vos sobre aquilo que eu
gostava de ter ouvido quando nesta
escola para mim é provavelmente a melhor
escola de líderes do país e aquilo que
eu estava a ser ouvido é são algumas
missões
essas lições que são fruto da minha
experiência que provavelmente houve na
altura estava a pensar em outras coisas
importantes não liguei muito
mas é sobre isto é sobre isso que eu vou
falar
eu e minha mulher eu nunca chega a sair
do colégio
a nossa vida traz buscar muitas vezes e
eu muitas vezes na minha vida no meu dia
a dia em lugares às vezes um pouco no
aspecto ainda acorda os valores que vai
quando eu quebrei minha especialidade há
cerca de 11 anos atrás do meu sonho era
trabalhar num hospital moderno
sensacional saiu de tecnologia com gente
tira uns meses atrás eu tive tudo que o
cruzeiro estava a trabalhar neste
hospital fantástico que era uma tenda sa
e tecnologia 0 no meio do sudão do sul
cheio de mentiras e nessa altura eu
percebi que há uma distância entre
aquilo que são os nossos sonhos e que a
nossa realidade isso é normal acontece é
fruto das pequenas decisões nós vamos
tomando no nosso dia a dia mas não são
os grandes decisões que nos levam para o
lado nossos sonhos são só as pequenas
coisas e há quem diga que quando
escolhemos um caminho anulamos o outro
eu não tenho tanta certeza disso
eu acho que os caminhos muitas vezes
cruzam mas aquilo que é importante e
acho que esta é a primeira lição que eu
gostava de deixar as suas vidas é que
nós temos que saber reconhecer que fui
tirada não está sempre no lugar nós
tínhamos nós temos que saber encontrar a
sociedade a nossa realidade daquilo que
temos no nosso dia a dia e eu não fui
para a cirurgia guerra é por acaso foi
foi um percurso mais uma vez foram as
pequenas decisões que eu fui tomando que
me foram wando é isso que me faz lembrar
sempre a história do da famosa
experiência do sapo que é colocado numa
panela de água a ferver e eu sei que se
eu colocar um saco com uma panela de
água ferver novamente em casa mas
acontece
eu saí da panela mas se eu colocar o
sapo numa panela com água fria e se eu
aquecer a panela é um grau por minuto
o sapo deixasse ficar até ela feira a um
processo de adaptação e que aconteceu
comigo foi isto
eu comecei em israel na altura da
segunda intifada
depois de uma missão humanitária na
indonésia quando foi do tsunami depois
mais tarde o temor também na missão
militar
mais recentemente no kosovo onde a
guerra e estes foram as minhas missões
de imersão
mas essas pequenas prensas fizeram
nenhuma pessoa diferente e a segunda
lição que eu gostava de deixar é não ter
medo de enfrentar as barreiras de usar
uma expressão muito típica do colégio
que eu acho delicioso chama carneirada
que ainda sabe o que quer dizer para
quem não anda carneirada e quando toda a
gente a linha por uma determinada idéia
sem saber ao certo porque toda a gente
vai atrás
um líder não alinha câmera nada menos
que seja eu o chefe da caminhada
portanto não tenho medo de ser diferente
não tenho medo de ir por um caminho que
a partida não parece ser até o pronto
toda a gente vai mas é muito importante
pensar pela nossa cabeça
a terceira lição que precisava deixar é
nunca perto com nenhuma oportunidade de
viajar em uma oportunidade de conhecer o
mundo nenhuma oportunidade de aprender
qualquer coisa nova e vocês ao longo da
nossa vida essas oportunidades vamos
passar pela frente
diariamente mas com muita freqüência não
espero que eu levo sempre uma história é
que há muitos anos atrás tinha 14 15
anos os pais moravam nos açores e um dia
numa esfera do colégio convidaram para
subir o pico da montanha do pico dos
meus 15 anos praia miúdas praia e fiquei
a pensar eu vou ter tantas oportunidades
ao longo da minha vida de subir o pico
porque o golpe
mas neste fim de semana vai passar uns
30 anos e ainda não subir o pico e está
sempre comigo
esta ideia de que há oportunidades que
passam e que se nós não aceitarmos
muitas vezes elas não volta ao voltar
muito mais tarde teremos que nos
esforçar muito mais por isso
portanto não perder nenhuma oportunidade
de viajar porque no fundo nós somos nós
somos aquilo que conhecemos nós estamos
aqui conhecemos do mundo
portanto quanto mais vocês conhecerem do
mundo mais ricos serão eu nunca tive um
pico mas já tive alguns destes peso e
esses são apenas alguns dos mais de 65
países que neste momento vivem conflitos
armados em todo mundo
nestes mais de 60 empresas cerca de 600
grupos armados lutam pelas mais variadas
coisas poder pela região recursos
naturais mas é uma coisa muito
interessante em relação a esse peso é
que a imagem que nós temos deus
nomeadamente nós que vivemos aqui é que
nos é passado pelos telejornais e quarta
lição que o mundo é muito mas muito
maior do que aquilo que nós vemos nos
telejornais e em todos estes países do
mundo
existem pessoas que não têm nada a ver
com a guerra existem pessoas que querem
simplesmente criar a sua família querem
ter um emprego querem poder chegar a
casa à noite ter uma feição querem poder
sair ao fim de semana que querem poder
ter férias e que não tem nada disto nós
não temos essa noção porque aquilo que
nos é dado a conhecer muitas vezes é
apenas uma pequena versão da história
muito muito lapidada
muitas vezes nada tem a ver com a
realidade aliás tivesse a ver eu
provavelmente nunca ter ido a nenhum
desses títulos
foi com este espírito que eu comecei a
fazer surgir guerra
nós somos muitas vezes levados de
helicóptero para um lugar inóspito
a vida é dura muitas vezes vivemos
entenda o que é possível de arranjar
trabalhamos em condições longe daquilo
que era o sonho mas fazemos o possível
com os recursos possíveis no local para
salvar
quantas vidas são possíveis e
trabalhamos muitas vezes em hospitais
estão tão sombrio estados estão
sobrelotados que debaixo das camas fazem
novas camas num carro mais lento e
quando eu estou no meio deste cenário
aquilo que eu penso sempre é porque
estou aqui e eu estou aqui muitas vezes
na maior parte das vezes porque a
inocentes no meio disto tudo a gente
realmente não tinha nada a ver com
aquela guerra a gente que estava ali por
acaso simplesmente queria fazer a sua
vida neste momento não tem possibilidade
de fazer e portanto a lição que eu
gostaria de dar é que nunca se esqueçam
que nós ligamos nozes este nosso pequeno
portugal esta nossa pequena europa não é
uma amostra do mundo afora
nós podemos nos queixar dos impostos
podemos nos queixar dos salários prémios
nos queixar do governo podemos descansar
das filas na segunda circular
podemos queixar dos exames temos que
achar muita coisa
mas quando vocês forem diferença quando
tirarem uma semaninha de cerezo pensa no
privilégio que isso representa conseguir
refere isso o luxo no mundo de hoje que
isso representa para nós vivemos mesmo
onze
uma das coisas que nós temos que
aprender a lidar nomeadamente quando
trabalhamos em servir guerra é aprender
a lidar com a frustração eu vou te
contar uma das histórias que mais marcou
nos últimos tempos foi foi no sudão é
uma bela manhã de verão estava a operar
amanhã e osso o som de um helicóptero e
obviamente está no hospital militar a
ouvir o som de um copto num cenário é eu
sabia que havia feridos a chegada minha
primeira sessão foi ok
ganhei mais dois ou três na minha
formatação ainda muito ocidental do que
um helicóptero não leva mais do que duas
pessoas dois feridos e não é da cirurgia
onde a enfermeira que estava de fora
eles não têm portas vai lavar aço e e
ver o que é que ficou na sala de
emergência e passado uns minutos com ar
muito aflito chegaram a 70 doentes
estava no meio da manhã eu ainda tinha
tínhamos programado a operar mais uns
quantos cantoria e só que eu vou
reavaliar pelos ventos que chegaram vez
algum que seja verdadeiramente
prioritário para o prazo agora quando eu
acabei de dizer isto
é o som do segundo helicópetero açúcar e
atrás dele observa o copo e em meia hora
eu recebi 210 baleado ea questão da
frustração imediatamente com sua ótima
porque uma equipa cirúrgica consegue
operar 78 doentes por dia
nós éramos apenas uma equipa cirúrgica
eu acho certo à noite tinha recolher
obrigatório tinha que sair do hospital
por questões de segurança e achatando em
terceiro o hospital deixando para trás
mais de 200 feridos
o que eu sabia que alguns irão morrer
durante 88 chorei chorei provavelmente
pela primeira vez numa missão e minha
convicção era que o que eu tenho que
fazer
eu sou uma gota no oceano uma gota no
oceano factual não falou nada até que
alguém disso não tem aquela coisa da
maneira que imaginar um quarto escuro e
num quarto escuro uma pequena vela faz
toda a diferença
realmente esta pequena mudança na forma
como vemos as coisas fez milagres outra
maneira e hoje acredito muito mais do
que o que estou a fazer
e para terminar a minha última missão
eu levo isto sempre tudo na bagagem
sempre que vou a emissão todos estes
conceitos num campo largo
mas há uma coisa que hoje estou
perfeitamente convicto unida tem que ser
generoso e tem que ser inspirador foi
generoso e não foi inspirador
não é ainda obrigado